it's a story that makes you angry or
everyday documents show that officials
suggested that the Parkland madmen be
committed a year or so ago which could
have prevented his murderous spree
deputy Scott Peterson was one of those
officials so the same deputy that
sheriff Israel through under the bus for
not confronting the shooter had actually
tried to do the right thing long before
that where was his boss then getting his
face painted on cars so why wasn't the
killer nab despite all the red flags
well what we saw was a county that did
half a right thing they saw something
did nothing it's an ugly lesson half a
right thing can be worse than one whole
wrong thing for pretends to be progress
and that prevents real solutions example
more lenient school discipline has been
hailed as progress but is it as national
reviews David French reports in 2013 the
Broward County School Board agreed with
law enforcement to limit on-campus
arrests did that affect this case could
be but we know what went wrong and it's
time to write it first fire Israel has
there ever been a more incompetent boob
in law enforcement
he's a power-hungry political hack then
finally let's create a database for sick
people who are tagged in civil court
based on testimony by officials teachers
and so on if you're on that list then no
gun
that's called a plan it's not a half a
plan and it's one that would save 17
lives so Jesse this article I think it
was a can't remember who was in the
Federalists or National Review about how
they they decided not to send kids like
to get involved with law enforcement and
because they didn't want kids to go to
jail right and there and there's been
some talk that that could have been the
reason why this guy got through it could
have been it started under the Obama
administration when they didn't want to
unfairly target minority students in
public schools because a lot of them
were getting arrested and it was having
repercussions on going to college and
things like that but at the same time
you have such an egregious case of
misbehavior and dangerous behavior from
this kid
you're cutting yourself if you're saying
I want to kill someone with a gun if
you're throwing your mother up against
the wall if you're doing all sorts of
outrageous things and you've been tried
to be civilly committed twice the FBI
has been tipped off two to three times
the police have visited your house
almost 30 to 50 times it's it's not like
there weren't laws and mechanisms in
place to prevent this so you can't point
to the gun everything on the state local
and federal level broke down and you
look at a guy like Israel who's taken
zero responsibility he cares more about
politics than Public Safety apparently
he doesn't even discuss crime he's
always about parade routes and whether
he can get a picture with the politician
he's not liked among the the people on
the ground there so what he did and said
he brought all his flunky friends from
softer law-enforcement backgrounds and
put him in charge of of places like
parkland and you see what happened
there's poor training there's poor
reaction time and the shooting in
Maryland today is interesting because it
was done with a pistol and an armed
person was at the school and neutralized
the shooter before he could do any more
damage now life kind of gives you
lessons and to not look at these lessons
is is is it's just not the right thing
because you're not hearing the media
talk about an ar-15 you're not hearing
the media talk about school safety
solutions with armed security guards
because it doesn't fit they're anti NRA
narratives so people need to look at
what happened in Maryland as a solution
to the problem you know Dana if the
sheriff is still there it's really I
mean I don't know like what do you have
to do to lose your job in Florida I
don't understand it I guess in some ways
there might be a recall you would
imagine from the parent I don't know I
don't know why they had it I do think
that it's pretty interesting that that's
or the deputy yeah looks so much grief
about temper his deputies lawyer said
repeatedly there is more to this story
and they were holding back I don't know
whether
just ticks me off about Israel even more
because if this guy Peterson was trying
to get this guy out of the school in
some place and if Israel did nothing and
then threw him under the bus what it
loathsome creature yep
terrible all right so here's the problem
I'm really so many missed opportunities
but it really goes back to even in 2016
they had the opportunity to you know put
away Nicolas can cruise and put him you
know an involuntary confinement where
then he would not have been able to
purchase these guns but people don't
take the opportunities as they're
presented when they knew that he was
mentally you know dangerous and unfit
person they're fought by creating a
further public safety risk that
manifests it in the shooting and loss of
multiple lives that's that's a problem
right there and then it's compounded by
the fact lack of leadership by Sheriff
Israel by the individuals on the seen a
number of missteps that resulted in a
further additional loss you know of life
so if you look at it this is sort of a
textbook example of how everything sort
of went wrong and converged together to
this perfect horrific storm of what
happened so it's not just about the gun
it's about what happened in the steps
and if you miss the rest of those pieces
of the puzzle this is going to repeat
itself because it's not just about the
weapon as we're seeing whether it's
bombs that you use that have different
detonator caps or whether it's pressure
cookers or whether it's a car you drive
into a crowd anything like that if if
the intention is there and you do not
see that that person is disturbed you
don't picking up the signals or the
clues of the intelligence gathering to
prevent it that's the first step because
if you get to that piece you don't even
get to the gun mm-hmm
and why it's not to knock law
enforcement because we don't hear about
the the acts that are prevented right
I'm there are things like this every day
that have probably been stopped so I
mean it's just in this case this might
be the most preventable gun spree I
think I've ever seen I Vegas I wouldn't
know how to stop that Vegas they were
called 29 times yeah yeah yeah the
Sheriff's Department yeah well you know
so you know I feel like I am in support
of gun control and I look at the polls I
see most Americans most gun owners are
in support of some kind of increase in
background
checks not allowing weapons of war to be
sold and the like and people want to
close gun show loopholes and the like so
I said I'm listening and I think the NRA
line is oh gosh you know this is a
result of inadequate law enforcement
it's not about access to guns but I
think access to guns is a part of the
equation and I could that's why the the
civil tag in a court would do that if
you said okay the the school officials
and the family members and those and
whoever police knew this guy was a a
problem that would bring the guns he
can't get a gun but there's no place to
put this guy yet except it's who uh but
an institution you think you know so you
were talking about the sheriff who has
his own problems but I think that in
fact as you say the deputy on the school
grounds had said this guy yeah should be
put away under the Baker Act or whatever
right and then you get though the social
workers and the therapists saying no it
wasn't the sheriff who said no it was
the mental health community that said no
at the time to this person I don't know
why be interesting to see those records
yeah but I will note I was reading about
this guy
Israel that the sheriff he's so
interesting he was a Republican who then
switched to be a Democrat and he's a
crony I'm like Roger stone is in this
story every story weeks ago where have
you been I tell you I was amazed